[Music]
season 20 a Big Brother let's jump into
Bailey she and Psyche see already in a
showmance yes did they jump in too soon
well the heart wants what the heart
wants Bryce they ditch I've been too
soon but that's Big Brother and you know
what we've had more marriages come out
of Big Brother than The Bachelor but the
good news is they're not flaunting their
show Matt's in everyone else's face
we've seen that in the past where last
summer you know show me they'll walk
around like arms hooked over each
other's shoulders and very you know it's
like a scene out of like grease or
something you know but they've been
keeping it you know somewhat locate and
swaggy has said like a what am I doing
here you know he is kicking himself
can't help who you fall in love with no
all three showmance is from last season
are still together I know
and Justin Cody are getting married yes
we know they got a million dollars from
the Amazing Race
not bad I think because I think she may
have moved to Texas for him yes yes so
you know he has a little girl and so
that works I don't know if it would have
worked if he lived in LA he is not an LA
person no and can you imagine her taking
him to the nightclubs he'd be like I am
having a good time yes
no I do absolutely and I was happy that
they want amazing ways it's not just
because they came out a big brother but
it's like they were excellent
competitors she better than he on Big
Brother he didn't listen to her at that
cost them both their games yeah so oh
that could mean all-stars in the future
yes do you see any other showmance is
happening
I think if esel who likes to be called
feci
and Haley's they like each other if s is
super super cute he's the tall he's the
dark he's the handsome I feel like you
could just protect me and wrap his arms
around me but Haley might be a little
bit Jordan like where you know I think
she like Jordan promised her mom or
grandma she wouldn't be seen you know
kissing someone on the show I think
they're gonna be a showmance now might
be a Jeff and Jordan showmance where
they say okay we like each other but
we're gonna wait till we're out of the
house yes - actually you know date
it seems she may have some feelings for
Tyler as well so there's a little bit of
a trying yeah but I he doesn't like her
okay ty doesn't like her and but Kaitlyn
even though she has a real-life
boyfriend outside the house she likes
vessel so she's I don't know it's like a
real-life soap opera
yeah Kaitlyn's been flirting with a lot
of people in the house hopefully she
doesn't upset anybody back home she
reminds me looks-wise in Nicole Bitchie
yes right doesn't she look like a vibe
wise she's kind of just Nicole Richie
all over yeah yeah you know kind of like
groovy hippy dippy a little bit open and
receiving to the energy that is taste in
your lap today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]